إذن ، كيف ستبدو الأيام الـ 11 الأخيرة من
رئاسة ترامب
بعد تمرد الأربعاء في
مبنى الكابيتول ، فإن محادثات المساءلة
والاستدعاء بالتعديل الخامس والعشرين
تعتبر جدية أن
الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب يخططون حاليًا
لإدخال مواد
عزل الرئيس ترامب بمجرد
إجرائه يوم الإثنين.
من الممكن أن يتم التصويت على مجلس النواب
في وقت مبكر إلى منتصف الأسبوع المقبل
، تتضمن النسخة الأخيرة مقالًا واحدًا
للتحريض على التمرد
مع مزيد من الدعم للمساءلة هذه
المرة
مع 131 من الرعاة المشاركين حتى الآن ،
ويأتي هذا بعد أن قالت رئيسة مجلس النواب نانسي
بيلوسي لتجمعها الانتخابي  اتصل
بعد ظهر يوم الجمعة
بأنها تفضل استقالة ترامب أو أن
يتم الاستناد إلى التعديل الخامس والعشرين
لتوضيح أنه إذا لم يحدث أي منهما
، فسوف يقوم مجلس النواب بالتقصير ، ويوم الجمعة
غرد الرئيس أنه لا يخطط
لحضور تنصيب الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن
ولا حتى بعد يوم واحد أخيرًا.  يعد
بانتقال سلمي للسلطة
مع الزخم لإزالة ترامب من
منصبه غرام  بسبب انضمام كلا الحزبين
إلي الآن للتلاعب بهذا الأمر في
الأيام المتبقية ،
وهي محاضرة إيلين ك مارك في السياسة العامة
في مدرسة هارفارد كينيدي
للحكم مؤلفة كتابين في السياسة الأولية ،
كل ما تحتاج لمعرفته
حول كيفية ترشيح أمريكا
لمرشحيها للرئاسة
و  لماذا يفشل الرؤساء وكيف يمكنهم أن
ينجحوا مرة أخرى؟
أعضاء مجلس الوزراء وليس هناك
ما يشير حتى الآن إلى أن
أيًا منهم سوف يسلك هذا الطريق ،
لذلك لا أعتقد أن التعديل الخامس والعشرين
بعيدًا عن الطاولة إلى حد كبير ، فإن العزل
يمثل تهديدًا مختلفًا
يمكن للمنزل أن ينجزه بسهولة
الأسبوع المقبل  المشكلة هي أن مجلس الشيوخ ليس من
المقرر أن يعود إلى منصبه حتى
التاسع عشر من كانون الثاني (يناير)
في اليوم السابق لتنصيبه حتى
تعرف أنه ربما يكونون قد شاركوا  يجب إجراء محاكمة
في الساعة التاسعة صباح يوم
يناير وإجراء تصويت ولكن هذا
سريع للغاية
آه للحصول على محاكمة لذلك ليس من الواضح أنه
حتى لو تم عزل المنزل
، فليس من الواضح أن مجلس الشيوخ
يمكن أن يدين
و  هناك أيضًا سؤال حول مدى
فائدة إدانة شخص ما في الساعة
11:30 يوم 20 يناير والذي يكون خارج المكتب
في الساعة 1201
يوم 20 يناير ، لذا فهذه
هي المشكلة حقًا هنا
وأعتقد أنهم يبحثون عن أشياء أخرى
أنا أيضًا كنت سأقول إنني أعتقد أن هناك مشكلة إضافية
تتمثل في ما إذا كان يمكنك
عزل رئيس بعد
أن تغادر منصبه.
يبدو أنه
لم يتم حلها ،
أردت أن أسألك شيئًا آخر على
الرغم من أنني أفكر أيضًا في
الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن وهذا هو
هل يريد الديموقراطيون حقًا أن تكون هذه هي
المشكلة
بالضبط في الوقت الذي
يحاولون فيه ذلك  اقلب صفحة وأطلق إدارة جديدة
، لذا فهذه نقطة جيدة حقًا ، أعني
أنك تعلم أن إحدى النظريات تقول
أنه إذا كانت التجربة معلقة نوعًا ما أو
لم تفتح بعد في مجلس الشيوخ
في التاسع عشر من كانون الثاني (يناير) ، فسيكون
عندها أمر  مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطي لأن
كامالا هاريس سيكون لها
التصويت المتأرجح هناك لإجراء
محاكمة ، ولست متأكدًا من أن جو بايدن
يريد حقًا القيام بذلك ، ولست متأكدًا من رغبته
في بدء
إدارته عندما يكون هناك الكثير
من الأشياء الملحة الأخرى
مثل  الحصول على اللقاحات في أحضان
الأمريكيين ،
فأنت تعلم القلق بشأن
محاكمة الإقالة ، لذلك
إذا كنت كذلك لو كنت جو بايدن ،
فلن أكون متحمسًا بشأن هذا الخيار